impatto sociale
se ne parla un sacco no e allo stesso
tempo non sappiamo bene di cosa si
tratti un po una leggenda metropolitana
non si sa come funzioni chi siano gli
attori di riferimento e soprattutto
perché sembra avere sempre più a che
fare con tutti invece che con pochi
addetti ai lavori una delle frasi
preferite su questo tema per me è il
fatto che l'impatto sociale non può più
permettersi di essere solo giusto deve
diventare efficace
infatti se ci pensiamo i progetti
sociali non hanno mai avuto un gran
movente funzionale ma emotivo è una cosa
vicende quella di voler fare del buono
il giusto in modo anche efficace però
quando guardiamo alle efficacia nei
progetti sociali
iniziamo a natale subito un paio di
problemi il primo tutte le problematiche
sociali sono with problems significa che
non sono problemi lineari sono proprio i
complessi sistemici che non sono
risolvibili né attaccando un aspetto
isolato né da un solo attore il secondo
la scala vita anche quando riusciamo a
trovare un progetto particolarmente
efficace nel 90 per cento dei casi non
ha una struttura che vi permetta di
arrivare in tutte le località dove
quella soluzione necessaria
questo è un problema
è un problema perché significa che anche
quando riusciamo a investire
sufficientemente tempi risorse ed
energie in trovare una soluzione
efficace
poi ci blocchiamo per modelli di diffuso
in obsoleti questa dinamica e
ulteriormente alimentata dal fatto che
siamo ancora attaccati a modelli
reattivi succede qualcosa c'è una crisi
agiamo d'urgenza cerchiamo di contenere
i danni con solissimi frammentate
isolate mai coordinate e con inutili
duplicazioni di sforzi solo ora grazie
alle informazioni inizia a sorgere un
nuovo paradigma quello pro attivo quello
che dice ma se sappiamo come funziona se
sappiamo cosa succede perché perché non
usiamo le informazioni che abbiamo a
disposizione dei modelli efficaci e
abbiamo contempo per prevenire il peggio
ma è davvero solo una questione di
risparmi di tempi i soldi energie
o c'è dell'altro la cosa interessante
che oggi la psicogenealogia ci insegna
che i traumi provocati da crisi come
l'olocausto
la malnutrizione cronica la violenza
sociale o la crisi rifugiati creano
delle conseguenze sociali psicologiche e
genetiche sì anche genetiche è stato
dimostrato che questi traumi hanno
conseguenze decennali che si trasmettono
di generazione in generazione
finché non vengono risolti o sanati
questo fatto ci mette davanti la
consapevolezza che fare il sistema
salvare risorse o prevenire o
collaborare o condividere modelli già
non è un'idea carina diventa un obbligo
morale
sì ma vi state chiedendo chi ha questo
bionda che le 5 pomeriggio di una
domenica ci racconta queste cose
complesse quindi giusto per conoscerci
meglio prima di continuare
ho 28 anni ho studiato con vicino brera
poi un anno a bilbao e ho giocato dodici
anni a pallavolo e mi sono laureata nel
2011 con una tesi su arte e psicologia e
sociologia bel mix
lo penso anch'io infatti quando mi sono
laureata nel avevo la più pallida e cosa
fare mi sentivo persa la mia passione
per il sociale per le politiche
internazionali per la tecnologia per la
psicologia non riuscivano a trovare un
canale per esprimersi
uno spazio ancora mina nel marco della
crisi generazionale ed economica che
conosciamo ormai qui da dieci anni poi
per me è arrivato il 2012 è l'anno in
cui ho permesso che la mia urgenza di
trovare il mio posto nel mondo avesse la
meglio e ha iniziato a viaggiare e
studiare i modelli l'impatto sociale di
sviluppo sostenibile in più di 20 paesi
nel mondo da macao qui a milano ai
bahrain israele dal cern ai campi
rifugiati in grecia e macedonia
io ho iniziato a notare qualcosa un
fattore in comune una nota un elemento
ricorrente che accomunava le realtà più
disparate del pianeta terra e cioè
l'insorgere di movimenti che mettevano a
disposizione modelli che semplicemente
aveva l'obiettivo di permettere alle
persone di agire ovunque esse fossero
tieni questo modello funziona usa dove
sei fai comunque parte di una cosa più
grande una causa più grande di te ma è
molto importante che tu agisca su scala
locale
questa cosa iniziato incuriosirmi
iniziato investigare e ho scoperto che
il valore di questo modello va molto più
in là di quello che potesse immaginare è
stato infatti dimostrato che quando il
nostro cervello ha esposto ai cessi di
flussi di informazioni su crisi problemi
traumi tragedie
sviluppiamo empatia sviluppiamo una
curva empatica e una conseguente
necessità di agire e reagire e fare
qualcosa in merito
in poche parole siamo disegnati per
vedere altre persone soffrire e
desiderare porre fine al gioco provoca
quella sofferenza
fin qui tutto bene no invece purtroppo è
anche stato dimostrato che quando questi
flussi informazioni ci sovrastano e
diventano troppi come oggi succede con i
nostri telefonini i nostri computer o
emilia
ci giochiamo il nostro cervello dice non
posso non sei tu un pericolo diretto
mi stai sovraccaricando di informazioni
su problemi e cose negative non mi dai
la possibilità di reagire in un modo che
io possa sentire la mia portata e stacca
la spina
le conseguenze le conosciamo tutti
isolamento distanza apatia disinteresse
ignoranza esclusione intolleranza
violenza questi sono fattori le cui
cause conosciamo molto bene ed elodie
nomeni nel 2015 quando ho capito che non
possiamo più permetterci di ignorarle
perché intorno a me c'erano solo
migliaia e migliaia di rifugiati
migranti ma anche in migliaia e migliaia
di cittadini e comunità locali e tutti
con la stessa domanda in testa che cosa
facciamo da dove iniziamo che cosa posso
fare io perché ho bisogno di fare
qualcosa e così è nato un portone
ho sentito l'urgenza di creare
un'organizzazione che si concentrasse
solo esclusivamente su trovare
analizzare e selezionare progetti
l'impatto sociale ambientale esistenti
efficaci e metterle a disposizione di
altre realtà in tutto il mondo
banalmente siamo un ponte tra il talento
il genio dell'impatto sociale locale che
mai potrebbe diffondere la sua formula
in tutti i luoghi necessari e studenti
imprenditori università ricercatori
governi imprese interessati in agire pre
cause sociali e semplicemente bloccati
dalla complessità di questo settore o
delle condizioni che li circondano il
progetto è nato un anno fa con abbiamo
deciso di lanciare un primo pilota
usando solo pdf abbiamo scelto un
progetto che abbia farò che permette di
creare dei posti donazioni di sangue in
caso di emergenze in scuole o in
palestra
3 era fondamentale per noi capire come
poter comunicare un progetto non
affinché venisse semplicemente
conosciuto quindi emotivo fattore
emotivo ma perché venisse replicato
funzionale il progetto in meno di tre
mesi è stato replicato in 19 città del
mondo quindi abbiamo continuato a
lavorare perché per noi è fondamentale
scoprire come per esempio usare big data
e domani ma shining per rimuovere quanto
più possibile i colli di bottiglia dei
processi attuali
abbiamo scelto un altro progetto in
occasione della settimana del cambio
climatico è un prodotto che permette a
qualunque educatore professore attivista
a fare un'attività con dei giovani in
cui si evidenzia la fondamentale
connessione tra quello che consumiamo
tutti i giorni e come ciò influenza il
cambio climatico
l'abbiamo lanciato un mese fa in inglese
e in spagnolo era stato tradotto da
comunità in francese in arabo in
portoghese verrà usato in più di
cinquanta città nel mondo
eviterete chi sa i budget di marketing 0
il budget di marketing all advertisement
sono la prima ragione per cui conosciamo
tantissimo dei progetti che non
necessariamente sono i migliori mentre
lardi rimangono nell'ombra introvabili
persi per sempre e quindi per noi
fondamentale riuscire a usare design
psicologia di informazioni e tecnologia
per creare un paradigma alternativo è
uno dei pilastri di questo paradigma
alternativo per noi è quello che
chiamiamo blueprint un blue print è una
formula la ricetta l'insieme dei
componenti che fa di un progetto un
progetto efficace la proposta di valore
quindi non usiamo più descrizioni
accademiche o emotive dal perché un
progetto è buono e giusto ma perché
funziona e quali sono gli elementi la
prende in considerazione quando una
persona l'organizzazione lo volesse
replicare in qualche ha proposto per
farvi un esempio
una delle cose
che specifichiamo nel blue print è la
tipologia di progetto è un intervento è
una cosa che dura poche settimane i
pochi mesi ed a mantenere nel tempo
qual è l'impatto generato qual è il
valore quella proposta
qual è il target ci sono i beneficiari
qual è il grado di complessità quanto è
accessibile ai famosi non addetti ai
lavori
quali sono i tempi e le risorse in media
necessarie incluse per esempio leggi
particolari o permessi governativi
qual è la compatibilità di contesto
in quali contesti è stato utilizzato
quindi in quali altri contesti
c'è un'altissima prova l'età che gli
effetti siano positivi e quali sono le
avvenute le applicazioni un ulteriore
riferimento
un'altra cosa che facciamo ci allineiamo
alle grandi aziende della sostenibilità
come l'agenda 20 30 che sta marcando un
nord al quale puntare tutti inclusi ma
non necessariamente stanno dando delle
formule che permettano persone
organizzazioni di agire cominciare
implementare raggiungere questi
obiettivi se penso a quella ragazza nel
2012 persa
oggi so che ho incontrato il mio posto
perché tutti i giorni conosco persone
organizzazioni la cui genialità i cui
progetti incredibili fanno impatto
sociale locale ma non ho mai pensato che
davvero arrivasse al momento in cui
potevano cambiare il mondo
un esempio
eccola drizzle un progetto di una
organizzazione in argentina
cordova che ha trovato il modo di
costruire con materiali locale una
pressa meccanica open source formula
aperta e prendere pet sporco quindi
neanche da lavare borse plastica e fare
dei mattoni chiude gli amatori tra
lamine di legno con cui si fanno dei
pannelli per costruire case sociali iper
isolanti iper esistenti e per leggere
cento per cento costruiti da donne da
comunità vulnerabili ma soprattutto un
terzo più economiche di qualunque
prefabbricato sociale questo è un
progetto che può fare la differenza per
le vite di persone in posti dove c'è
plastica assenza di case come per
esempio nelle località affette da
disastri naturali
un altro progetto questo tale california
prendono la ma mai prende autobus che
già non possono circolare per eccessive
emissioni di co2 per esempio perché sono
vecchi li svuota di dipingere ci metti
un bagno una doccia e creati posti
immobili di igiene che girano per la
città e permettono il senzatetto non
solo appunto di avere accesso all igiene
basica ma fare un colloquio di lavoro o
rivedere i loro cari o ancora litro
slide che già non usa solo bottiglie di
plastica riciclate ma ricicla cassette
elettriche lanterna cherosene batterie e
insegna comunità locali vulnerabili in
tutto il mondo come usare i loro
strumenti le loro capacità per costruire
lampade solari lavorando anche non solo
successo energia maleducazione o
sicurezza o accesso wifi
queste sono progetti che potrebbero mai
diventare monopoli multinazionali no le
loro formule però non avrebbero valore
in ogni singola località in cui vengano
replicate io credo si è allora
facciamolo in un momento di crisi
storica con soluzioni dall'alto
inesistenti o che non ci rappresentano
riappropriamoci della capacità di agire
di creare di offrire alternative di
creare un settore dell'impresa sociale
davvero efficace davvero misurato e
davvero inclusivo perché lo sappiamo che
girarci dall'altra parte non fa che
allontanarci dalla consapevolezza che
già non si tratta di responsabilità
sociale ma di opportunità sociale perché
sognare un futuro migliore
e rendersi conto di avere tutti i mezzi
per costruirlo è la nostra più grande
opportunità oggi dicono che se vuoi puoi
e se poi deve quindi qual è il vostro
blueprint grazie
[Applauso]